premier coureur français 92 yens 189
troisième 185 quatrième voire 185
viennent les allemands trading et ne
rigolaient surtout pas je suis
comédienne je suis actrice on me propose
une chose et c'est mon métier d'accepter
ou de refuser
moi je attache beaucoup d'importance au
dîner avec le metteur en scène avant
c'est avec le metteur en scène en dînant
avec le metteur en scène avant que je
décide si je pourrais m'en tente si le
mariage peut se taire ou nous voilà
c'est comme ça on n'achète pas je suis
avec de l'argent il est mon cher ami
jean michel illien d'avoir dit ça il te
passe l'argent
vraiment madame et voilà voilà
les dictateurs pour moi ce sont des
personnages grotesques
je le vois toujours en grotesque que ce
soit il plaire ou d'autres je ne veux
pas les citer tous
nous en avons eu dans l'histoire est
pour moi un dictateur est toujours un
personnage théâtralement grossesse et
nous allons le rendre le plus grotesque
possible pour que dans l'histoire
les enfants ne voient dans ce personnage
atroce que le rire à travers ce
personnage en a pas non il faut jamais
me demandez ce que vous aviez envie
d'être eva braun ont les choses se
présentent autrement dans ma carrière
on me propose ça ça me plaît je le fais
à ma famille 20 veuillez donner le coup
d'envoi
alors c'est très simple vous allez tout
est là avec le plie la voilà maintenant
peut-être que dans l'histoire les
dictateurs se diront et y aura peut-être
deux acteurs qui vont nous mettre en
boîte
faisons attention pour l'histoire sous
ne soyons pas dictateur soyons
simplement homme politique c'est va vers
ça que nous voulons aller jusqu'à une
idée ces six avantages et s'est fait
déjà l'idée il ya trente ans d'un
certain charlie chaplin il n'a hélas pas
réussi peut-être henri tisot alice
appris que feront ils mieux